qui manque aussi ce qui était compliqué
de pouvoir inventer qu'on soit en 1880
où en 2004
d'ailleurs la loi de 2004 elle émane
d'une directive est là donc c'est une
directive qui a été écrite en 99 quand
on sent quand même qu'il ya beaucoup
d'années qui sont passés et donc à
l'époque le concept de la modération
n'était pas aussi utile n'était pas
aussi avancé et modérée n'est pas
censuré je préfère anticiper les
réponses qui vous qui vous qui vont être
faites
or aujourd'hui lorsque lorsqu'on a mal
sur internet il eu le temps de la
douleur n'a rien à voir avec le temps du
référé ou dut ou du contentieux au fond
et donc il fallait je suis pas monsieur
havyarimana m'a bien mais l'idée c'est
qu'il fallait trouver des solutions
alors il se trouve qu'en allemagne il ya
eu un premier exemple qui n'a pas été
une catastrophe puisque ça fait deux ans
que cette loi est en place et eu un
premier rapport qui est sorti au mois de
juillet et qui montrent que seulement
10% des contenus qui sont signalés sont
effectivement enlevé par les plateformes
c'est à dire qu'on est très loin de la
dictature et de la censure 10 %
seulement sont enlevés par le par les
plateformes on s'aperçoit que facebook
et twitter ont des comportements
différents
facebook a d'ailleurs été condamnée à 2
millions d'euros en allemagne
parce que ce n'était pas assez clair la
manière dont on pouvait faire des
différents signalements
mais ça montre bien que on n'est pas en
train de parler de censure
[Musique]